NAZMUL IDRIS: Hi, everyone.
I'm Nazmul.
And I'm a developer.
IZABEL IDRIS: And
hi, I'm Izabel.
I'm a designer.
In today's episode of "UX Design
for Developers," we're
going to talk about how to
create really awesome social
user experiences.
We're going to talk about some
best practices and some design
patterns that you guys can use
to implement social in your
applications.
And today we have a very special
guest named Sam.
SAM STERN: Hi, I'm Sam.
And I'm a developer for Google+
Developer relations.
IZABEL IDRIS: So, I'm
going to start off
by asking some questions.
Nazmul, there's a lot of
buzz around Social.
But tell us, what is social and
why it's important, and
what's the value for us
using it in our apps?
NAZMUL IDRIS: So if you go to
the slides, there's really two
main concepts we have to think
about when we're thinking
about social, because social
is like a buzzword--
everybody uses it and everybody
interprets it in a
different way.
So what really is social?
There's really two main concepts
that make up social.
And they are having a portable
identity that you could take
with you and apply to any
application on the internet--
and so when you say things like
sign in with Google or
log in with Facebook, that's
what we're talking about.
The other concept is sharing
activities, which means that
whatever actions or activities
you perform in whatever
application, the idea is that
you should be able to take
those activities and then expose
it or share it with an
audience of your choice.
And so when you put these two
together, you have the
beginnings of social.
Now, those concepts are
implemented very specifically
across various social
network providers.
So the three main features that
are almost everybody has
are sign-in, personalization,
and sharing.
So sign-in, that really, from a
user experience perspective,
that feature addresses reducing
friction that a user
has to experience when they
first encounter your
application.
So it really eliminates having
to create a new account by
providing information that you
already stored somewhere else,
like in your profile for
Google+, for example.
So the idea there is that if you
sign in with a provider,
you don't have to
provide all that
information all over again.
And that makes logging in and
account creation totally
seamless and really,
really easy.
So the next thing is once you
signed in, how does the
application respond to the
fact you've signed in?
How is it showing you that there
is a signed in state?
So that's when personalization
comes in.
And personalization is the
act of your application,
essentially taking things like
your name, your profile
picture, and any other relevant
information, like
what Google Now does sometimes,
when it's your
birthday, it says, hey,
happy birthday, Sam.
Not that it's Sam's birthday
today, just an example.
But so personalization is key in
making you feel at home in
your application.
And, finally, sharing.
Sharing is just taking certain
application activities and
then exposing them to whatever
audience in a
way that makes sense.
And different or social network
providers do it
differently.
IZABEL IDRIS: OK, so now that
we know a little bit about
social, should we
put in our apps?
And how are our end users going
to benefit from social?
NAZMUL IDRIS: That's actually
a really good question.
There are really two things
to consider from the user
experience perspective to
answer the question.
And those are do you have
a signed-in experience?
And you have an enormous
experience?
So what do those mean?
An anonymous experience is
you've, for example, gone to
amazon.com.
You haven't signed in, and
it doesn't know who you.
Are it's showing you just a
catalogue of Amazon's products.
If your application can have a
signed out experience, or an
anonymous experience, and also
signed in inexperienced, just
like, again, with Amazon--
when you're signed in, it
knows who you are, it gives
you your wish list, your
recommendations, your shopping
cart and so on.
That's an example of an
application that can have both
an anonymous experience and
a signed in experience.
So sometimes, if you're--
So Gmail is actually another
example, different than
Amazon, because Gmail does not
have an anonymous experience.
You have to signed in to Gmail
for Gmail to make any sense.
So to answer the question, if
your application can do
without a signed-in experience,
then you really
have to think about
how to make your
social integration special.
Don't just put social
into an application
because it's a buzzword.
It has to make sense in the
context of your application.
Now, if you have a certain type
of application which does
not have an anonymous
experience, then you don't
have a choice but to
make it social.
And in that case, also, make
sure that you do a really good
integration, because a bad
integration with social will
end up turning people off, more
than actually engaging
them or delighting them.
IZABEL IDRIS: There's one thing
I wanted to mention,
because social features can
surface in your application in
many places.
I think it really makes sense
for social to be taken into
consideration early
on in the design.
Designers, PMs, and developers
should all think about how
social is going to surface in
the application, because it
really goes into the DNA
of the application.
A lot of people think social is
just a Share button or just
a Login button, but I think it
needs to be really thought of
in a more holistic way early
on in your project.
So Sam, should people implement
these social
features on their own?
How should they go about this?
SAM STERN: So I think it's
tempting for a lot of people
to say, my application
needs a messaging
service, let's build messaging.
But there are people--
and these are social providers--
that do this all
day, and they do it very well.
And you shouldn't reinvent the
wheel, we should let these
social networks do what
they do best.
And sort of outsource
your social
features to these networks.
So if you're going to have a
friends model, you should
really consider off loading that
to Google+ or Facebook,
or something that can provide
you with a social model.
So there's no need, especially
if you are a startup, to spend
all this effort implementing
social features that have
almost definitely been done
better by someone else.
IZABEL IDRIS: So from an end
user perspective, why do you
think end users choose
social login?
And how do they choose which
provider to log in with?
SAM STERN: I think users choose
social login, like
Nazmul said, to reduce
friction.
Almost always if you can
click once and be
logged into a new service.
And, yeah, there's a trust
factor there too, because
they've already made an account
with the social
provider, so they've already
given their trust to that
application.
This way they don't have to
further distribute their trust
among more developers that they
might not know too well.
And they choose a social
provider based on--
assuming there are multiple
offers-- based
on the feature sets.
So you might choose Facebook,
because you're dying to share
everything you do with your
friends, and you might choose
LinkedIn, because you want to
connect with your coworkers.
So that's a portable identity.
And which provider you
choose is also a data
point in that identity.
IZABEL IDRIS: So as a developer,
should we choose to
implement social login?
And if so, should we implement
multiple providers?
SAM STERN: I think it's
important for developers who
are implementing social login
to consider multiple
providers, Because it's
one more thing you can
know about your user.
It's a choice they're making,
and you should be able to
react to that choice.
Like the example I gave earlier,
if someone chooses to
log in with LinkedIn, that's
saying something about how
they intend to use
your application.
And you only know the
choice they made, if
you give them a choice.
So if you just offer to sign
them in with Google+, the only
thing you're learning is do they
have a Google+ or not.
But if you give them multiple
providers, that's one more
thing you can learn about your
users, and one more way your
website can react and create
a great experience.
IZABEL IDRIS: So now that we
know about all the cool things
we can do with social, let's
talk about the developer
experience.
What's the best way to
implement social?
SAM STERN: Implementing social
is not very hard, but it's
hard to do well.
So there's a lot of code you
can just drop into your
application, but that can
quickly make things messy.
And you have to think
about why you're
implementing social.
To make your users able
to do more things.
And your code should reflect
that you've expanded the
abilities of your users.
So you don't want to have your
code littered with branching
statements, like if the user's
signing in with Google, share
it to Google, if they're signing
in with Facebook,
share it to Facebook, because
that's really leaking your
social logic into your business
logic and defeating
the point of why you did this
in the first place.
You want to just make
it seem like your
app has more functions.
So your code should
reflect this.
And you want to separate the
social logic entirely so that
you just say, the user has
bought a widget and the user
is sharing buying a widget.
And you let some other code or
library somewhere handle what
network they're sharing
this to, how exactly
that's being done.
And of course, this will be
harder at the very beginning,
when it might be easier
just to drop in code.
But the idea is as you add more
features, maybe you want
to add two or three more login
providers as you really get
the hang of this, it's going to
be so much easier if you do
this in a principaled matter and
think of that as expanding
the ability of your users, and
not just dropping code
snippets throughout
your application.
NAZMUL IDRIS: That
makes sense.
It's like using separation of
concerns, essentially, to
isolate different providers
and make sure that you can
express social capabilities of
your application but leave it
up to your provider
implementations.
Very much like Android does it
with location providers.
Where you can ask Android,
hey, give me a location
provider and give it
to your criteria.
And then Android might hand you
different ones-- like some
consume more batteries, some
give you more accurate
readings, and then others give
you quick readings, but they
might not be as accurate.
So it's kind of like that, where
they've basically taken
this very complex Location
Provider model--
or very many different providers
and then abstract it
to a much simpler model.
Is that--
SAM STERN: Yeah, that's right.
And it's also-- a way to think
about it is you wouldn't let
the social features take over
your entire UI, it's an
extension of your business.
And so if someone's looking at
your code and you onboarding
new developers, they should
see it that way too.
This is an extension and this
is not the driving force.
NAZMUL IDRIS: That
makes sense.
So you almost don't want to
denature the DNA, if you will,
of your application by thinking
of it just as a
conduit for sharing
activities.
SAM STERN: Right.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Or for how do you
accommodate a portable identity?
It's like you have to maintain
who you are, what your
application was meant to do,
and then augment it with
social features, as it makes
sense, in the context of your
application and the experience
you're delivering.
SAM STERN: Exactly.
IZABEL IDRIS: How does
everything we've discussed
here today affect the user
experience for our end users?
NAZMUL IDRIS: That's a
really good question.
If your application allows or
provides the user a choice to
sign in with multiple providers,
then it's very,
very important in the user
experience to really make this
user feel good about the choice
that they've made.
So a really, really bad design
pattern, an anti-pattern,
would be that if you asked them
to basically choose one
provider, then in the flow of
your application you keep
prompting them to use another
provider, as if you really
wanted them to sign in with this
other provider, but you
were kind of--
you're not really OK with them
signing in with the provider
they chose, but you're
tolerating it.
But you really wanted them to
use the other provider.
So if your application is
delivering that tone or that
mood to the user, then that's
not really good, because then
the user feels bad that they've
chosen the wrong provider.
Also, another anti-pattern is do
not ask users to sign with
every single provider that they
might have an account on.
That's redundant.
And unless you can
deliver value--
and you have to let the user
know upfront what value they
are going to get from actually
connecting your application to
all their identities--
unless you can give them this
value proposition upfront,
it's a really, really bad idea
to ask them to connect to
every single provider.
Because the whole point,
if you remember,
was to remove friction.
And now what you've done is
you've layered more friction
onto a process that's supposed
to be frictionless.
IZABEL IDRIS: It takes
away value.
It almost makes it feel like
you just want their dates,
you're just trying to get at
their friends or their data.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Exactly.
And that also is a very bad
thing to do is to give the
impression that when you're
asking somebody to sign in
with their identity, you have to
deliver an experience that
was better than if they had
an anonymous experience.
If you're not doing that, then
why are you doing social
integration?
Additionally, if you're asking
them for multiple identities,
then there has to be a value
proposition to the user, which
is pretty clear, and they
have to see that in your
experience as well.
That means that you're unlocking
certain capabilities
that might not have existed if
you had a single provider.
So unless you can do all of
the above, it's not a good
idea to actually ask them
from multiple providers.
SAM STERN: You said before about
making the application
seem like it was built for
the choice the user made.
Could you elaborate on
that a little bit?
NAZMUL IDRIS: Sure.
So for example, if you're
signing in with something like
LinkedIn, then the type of
information or the activities
that your application should
share should be more
work-related.
Versus, let's say, you've signed
in with Facebook, where
that could be more personal
stuff, more fun stuff.
Or, let's say, you signed in
with GitHub, where now we're
talking more technical stuff,
like coding oriented.
So the application that you're
building obviously has a
certain user experience in mind,
it does certain things.
And so you should align these
identity providers with what
you're trying to deliver, and
then when there is alignment,
then the user will feel like
they're getting a tremendous
amount of value from the choice
they've made, and
they'll feel good about having
made that choice.
Does that answer
your question?
SAM STERN: Yeah, I think that
makes a lot of sense.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Cool.
IZABEL IDRIS: I think for one
thing that can really enhance
the user experience is, like
with Google search results
too, you can see which one of
your friends has +1 certain
sites, or even the Google Play
store, you can see which one
of your friends in Google+
have +1 certain items.
And that can help you make
better decisions.
And I think that adds
a lot of value.
NAZMUL IDRIS: That true.
The social proof is a really,
really big component of
actually enhancing my
experience, because if I'm
looking for a particular
application in Google Play,
and Sam has +1'ed it.
I trust Sam, Sam is awesome.
So then by extension, I think
this application is good,
because Sam said that it was
a really application.
And vice versa, if Sam gives
it a negative review, then
obviously, I would take that
data point in too.
I would basically trust that
interview more than an
anonymous review.
So for example, if I'm signed
into Amazon, then I have a lot
of reviews, with a lot of
ratings, and I'm not really
sure whether--
I don't know these people.
So if I can see Sam reviewing
something, I have much more
confidence in that review
then if it's
just some random person.
Even if those reviews
are good.
It's just a human thing.
And again, when we talk about
social here, it's really
important to think of this as
a human experience, because
social should not be
some feature set.
Like I mentioned three
features--
sign-in, personalization,
and sharing.
Social is just not a composite
of these features, social is
something that we
do as humans.
And these features are trying
to enhance what we would
normally do anyway as people.
So that's, I think, another
kind of meta concept.
But I think it's really
important to now.
And that's why we talked about
making users feel good about
the choice they've
made, and so on.
SAM STERN: If you're a developer
and you're looking
to get started with multiple
providers, and Nazmul has
especially convinced you that
this can really add advantage
to your application, I've done
another GDL on this topic and
I wrote a tutorial on
how to get started
with multiple providers.
And the links are below, if you
want to get started and
get coding.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Yes, there is a
good example, actually, of how
to use Google+ and Facebook.
And I think the application
is called Wigwam now.
SAM STERN: Yeah, and there's
also code samples on GitHub
[INAUDIBLE] as well.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Cool.
And it's a web app and a mobile
application, right?
SAM STERN: That's right.
NAZMUL IDRIS: Cool, awesome.
IZABEL IDRIS: Well, thanks,
everyone, for watching today's
episode of "UX Design for
Developers." We'll see you,
guys, next time.